Попалися!!! Я вам покажу!
Те, що роблять ці школярі, більше нагадує дитячу забавку.
Однак насправді йдеться про підготовку до серйозної небезпеки:
стрілянини в школі.
Що робити, якщо нападник зі зброєю вривається в клас?
Якщо втекти неможливо? Напад – найкращий захист!
Саме такий сценарій німецькі семикласники розігрують зі своїм викладачем.
Гадаю, таке могло б статися, і якщо це таки станеться,
то все буде не так гладко, як зараз.
І тоді мені дійсно страшно, що все піде не так.
Як правильно забарикадуватись у класі –
ще один важливий аспект вправи.
Більшість учнів знають, що коли спрацьовує пожежна сигналізація,
треба вибігати з приміщення.
Проте далеко не всі усвідомлюють,
що в випадку з нападником треба робити протилежне.
Саме цим намагається поділитися Гайнц Крафт.
Разом із учителями гімназії в Гемері він запровадив
підготовку учнів до кризових ситуацій кілька років тому.
Щоправда, для Німеччини це радше виняток:
мало де школярів так активно готують
до ймовірного збройного нападу.
На мій погляд, школи недостатньо готові, оскільки
тема збройного нападу зазвичай табуйована.
Для вчителів проводяться тренінги.
А от тренінги чи інформаційні уроки для учнів
зазвичай відхиляються з доволі поверхневим, на мою думку, аргументом:
мовляв, не варто, непокоїти школярів.
Імовірність стрілянини в школі в Німеччині порівняно низька,
але тема присутня у свідомості школярів.
Зокрема й через стрілянину у школі у Флориді.
Ви можете уявити, щось таке у нашій школі?
Порівняно багато учнів можуть. Проте вони
не відчувають загрози так, як школярі у США.
Те, що відбувається у США, вже занадто, особливо з усією зброєю.
Це однозначно інакше, ніж у нас в Німеччині.
По-моєму, добре, що в Німеччині не так легко отримати зброю.
Через те, що закони про зброю тут значно суворіші
і не всі можуть її придбати, я вважаю,
відчуття безпеки зовсім інше.
Численні критики вважають кризові тренування для школярів
непотрібною панікою, але учні вбачають у них сенс.
Малоймовірно, що щось колись може статися,
але якщо це станеться, то я знаю точно, як діяти.
І найбільша перевага для  школярів -
отримана завдяки тренінгу впевненість у собі.
Звичайно, кожен сподівається
ніколи не скористатися здобутими знаннями,
але вони почуваються підготовленими
і не мають панічного страху.